[Music]
it's almost almost backyard barbecue
season now I know that you love
barbecuing Andy I've had nobody replace
many times I have and if you'll remember
last year with the help of Lowe's I set
up a whole backyard barbecue set on the
back of a flatbed truck and drove it
around oh that was fun it was all around
La with a backyard barbecue on a truck
well this year I'm gonna stay in one
place and I'm gonna show viewers how to
throw the ultimate backyard party and I
shot it last week with a camera crew and
I'd like everyone to check it out just
say summertime means backyard fun and
Lowe's is the number one destination to
celebrate summer so the good people at
Lowe's are gonna help me outfit this
backyard to be the ultimate in summer
fun now when I say the good people at
Lowe's I don't mean to imply that
there's bad people at Lowe's my
experience they've been nothing but
lovely but I mean there are humans so
there might be a few bad apples in the
bunch
I can't say that for sure and that's not
really the point of this the point is to
have fun it's summertime let's go hi
there hey how you doing good yeah this
is a ban these from Lowe's
I'm Andy Andy Ben brought a whole
truckload of stuff furniture and
fireplaces a lot of pool stuff right
everything we need for the backyard yeah
so there's a lot of work to do for the
set up to this party for the guests
arrive right all kinds yeah well then I
should introduce you to somebody
this is Paul he's my body double for all
the manual Labor's except this thing up
I'll be over here if you need
[Applause]
[Music]
get back in the band go oh lot of work
then looks great though good job we did
it but what's the backyard gathering
without family and friends that's why
we've called a Hollywood casting agency
to give me the family and friends that I
deserve all right the party's going
great but we need some tunes that's why
I've got the basic table bands generic
backyard barbecues it sounds like all
your favorite summertime hits but it's
not
[Music]
hey guys do you like games because I got
a great game for you
it's called build uncle Andy's Arbor
here's the game parts right here what do
you say guys dig in guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Andy what are all these people doing in
my backyard you know we're just having a
little summer time get together with a
bunch of actors I hired Andy sometimes
about making memories it's about having
fun times with people that you truly
care about not actors actors are
worthless
what can we say then oh hell no y'all
gots to go let's go Paul get the grill
no the grill stays the grill space come
on Paul that wind looks nice
[Music]
[Applause]
great job Andy thanks Conan and remember
Lowe's is the number-one destination for
celebrating summer so well said Andy oh
well said